what is causing the white lung oh this
is okay remember when these photos came
out of people's lungs and they were
white yeah now it's like happening all
over again it's kind of it's kind of
wild because you know basically you I I
don't think all of you in the band but
some many of you I think have stories of
defying the lockdowns the restrictions
the mandates M and so the day you're
like Hey we're going to come on and
we're going to talk about this we get
this story about it's it's all starting
again and now of course they are saying
no no don't worry there's not going to
be another pandemic Health backs were
saying don't worry about it but that's
the other thing they did when Co first
started you had fouchi saying that you
didn't have to wear mask don't worry
it's not that big a deal YouTube was
actually restricting content that was
talking about it and then all of a
sudden it turned into the whole country
locking down restrictions on businesses
mandates for for certain Medical
Treatments oh I remember I'm hoping that
we don't go there but hey welcome to the
show guys what what a day to join us
well I couldn't believe it you you had
that up earlier on the screen I said to
you I'm like that's not from today